Nous nous intéressons à plus que ça.
Nous nous intéressons au climat.
Cela représente des années, des millénaires
et nous devons aller à de plus petites échelles.
Ce que nous ne pouvons pas résoudre,
les processus à échelle inférieure,
nous devons trouver un moyen de faire des approximations.
C'est un défi immense.
Les modèles climatiques des années 1990
prenaient un plus petit tableau,
seulement 3 ordres de grandeur.
Les modèles des années 2010
ce sur quoi nous travaillons en ce moment ;
4 ordres de grandeur.
Il nous en faut encore 14.
Nous augmentons notre capacité
à les simuler au rythme d'environ
un ordre de grandeur tous les 10 ans.
Un ordre de grandeur spatial supplémentaire,
c'est 10 000 fois plus de calculs.
Nous ajoutons toujours plus de choses,
plus de questions à ces différents modèles.
À quoi ressemble un modèle climatique ?
C'est un vieux modèle, j'en conviens,
une carte perforée, une simple ligne en Fortran.
On n'utilise plus les cartes perforées.
On utilise encore Fortran cependant.
Des idées ultramodernes comme C
n'ont pas eu un gros impact
sur la communauté de modélisation du climat.
Mais comment peut-on s'y prendre ?
Comment passer de la complexité
à une ligne de code ?
Nous le faisons petit à petit.
Voici une image de la banquise
prise au dessus de l'Arctique.
Nous pouvons consulter les différentes équations
qui entrent dans la formation de la glace,
dans sa fonte ou dans sa transformation.
Nous pouvons constater les fluctuations.
Nous pouvons voir la vitesse à laquelle
la neige se transforme en glace.
Nous pouvons entrer tout ça dans un code.
Ces modèles font environ
un million de lignes de code en ce moment,
et augmentent de dizaines de milliers
chaque année.
Vous pouvez regarder ce morceau,
mais vous pouvez en regarder d'autres aussi.
Qu'arrive-t-il quand il y a des nuages ?
Lorsque les nuages se forment,
lorsqu'ils se dissipent, lorsqu'il pleut ?
C'est un autre morceau.
Qu'arrive-t-il lorsque la radiation
émanant du soleil, traversant l'atmosphère,
est absorbée et réfléchie ?
Nous pouvons aussi encoder ces petits morceaux-là.
Il y a d'autres morceaux :
Le vent qui modifie les courants marins.
On peut parler du rôle qu'a la végétation
dans le cycle de l'eau du sol
vers l'atmosphère.
Chacun de ces différents éléments
peuvent être encapsulés et systématisés.
Ces pièces s'additionnent pour former un tout.
Vous obtenez alors quelque chose comme ça.
Vous obtenez une représentation magnifique
de ce qui se passe dans le système climatique,
dans lequel chacun
des motifs émergents que vous voyez,
les tourbillons dans l'océan Austral,
le cyclone tropical dans le golfe du Mexique,
et il y en a 2 autres qui vont apparaître
dans le Pacifique incessamment,
ces flots d'eau atmosphérique,
toutes ces propriétés émergentes
qui proviennent des interactions
de tous ces processus à petite échelle que j'ai mentionnés.
Aucun code ne dit :
« Fais un remous dans l'océan Austral. »
Aucun code ne dit : « Il doit y avoir
2 cyclones tropicaux qui tournoient l'un autour de l'autre. »
Toutes ces événements sont des propriétés émergentes.
C'est très bien. C'est excellent.
Mais ce qu'on veut vraiment savoir,
c'est : qu'arrive-t-il à ces propriétés
lorsque l'on perturbe le système ?
Lorsque quelque chose change, qu'arrive-t-il à ces propriétés ?
Il y a beaucoup de façons différentes de troubler le système.
Il y a des oscillations dans l'orbite de la planète
sur des périodes de centaines de milliers d'années
qui changent le climat.
Il y a des changements dans les cycles solaires,
tout les 11 ans et plus, qui changent le climat.
De grands volcans entrent en éruption et provoquent un changement climatique.
Des changements dans la combustion de biomasse, dans la fumée,
dans les particules d'aérosols ; toutes ces choses
changent le climat.
Le trou d'ozone a changé le climat.
La déforestation change le climat
en changeant les propriétés de surface
et la façon dont l'eau s'évapore
et se déplace dans le système.
Les trainées de condensation changent le climat
en créant des nuages là où il n'y en avait pas auparavant,
et bien sûr, les gaz à effet de serre changent le système.
Chacune de ces perturbations
nous donne des indices
pour évaluer notre compréhension
de ce système.
Nous pouvons donc examiner
ce qu'est notre habileté à faire des modèles.
J'utilise le mot « habileté » en connaissance de cause :
les modèles ne sont ni bon ni mauvais ; ils sont toujours mauvais.
Ils sont toujours des approximations.
Vous devez vous demander
si un modèle vous fournit plus d'informations
que vous en auriez autrement.
Si oui, c'est utile.
Voici l'effet du trou de la couche d'ozone
sur la pression au niveau de la mer ; basse pression, haute pression
autour des océans austraux, autour de l'Antarctique.
Voici les données observées.
Voici les données modélisées.
La correspondance est plutôt bonne
car on comprend les lois de la physique
qui régissent les températures dans la stratosphère
et leurs effets sur les vents
autour des océans austraux.
Nous pouvons prendre d'autres exemples.
L'éruption du Pinatubo en 1991
a jeté d'énormes quantités d'aérosols, des petites particules,
dans la stratosphère.
Ça a changé l'équilibre de la radiation sur toute la Terre.
Moins d'énergie entrait dans l'atmosphère qu'avant,
refroidissant ainsi la planète.
Ces lignes rouges et ces lignes vertes
représentent les différences entre ce que nous attendions
et ce qui s'est réellement produit.
Les modèles sont utiles,
non seulement dans le sens global,
mais également dans les motifs régionaux.
Je pourrais vous présenter des dizaines d'autres exemples :
notre connaissance quant aux cycles solaires,
qui modifient l'ozone dans la stratosphère ;
notre connaissance concernant les changements dans l'orbite terrestre
depuis 6 000 ans.
On peut prendre ça en compte et les modèles sont utiles.
Les modèles sont utiles pour comprendre les nappes de glace
20 000 ans en arrière.
Les modèles sont utiles
quand il est question des tendances du 20e siècle
au fil des décennies.
On réussit à modéliser
les débordements des lacs dans l'Atlantique Nord
il y a 8 000 ans.
Et nous pouvons faire correspondre les données.
Chacune de ces cibles,
chacune de ces évaluations,
nous ont apporté une vision plus étendue
de ces modèles
et nous a menés vers de plus en plus
de situations complexes où l'on peut se demander
de plus en plus de questions intéressantes
comme, comment la poussière provenant du Sahara,
en orange ici,
interagit-elle avec les cyclones tropicaux de l'Atlantique?
De quel façon les aérosols organiques de la combustion de la biomasse,
représentés par les points rouges,
et les structures de nuages et de pluie se croisent-ils ?
Comment la pollution, que vous pouvez voir
dans les volutes blanches de sulfates polluants en Europe,
affecte-t-elle la température à la surface
et la lumière du soleil reçue au sol ?
Nous pouvons voir ces phénomènes partout sur la planète.
On peut voir la pollution en Chine
On peut voir les effets de tempêtes
sur les particules de sel de mer dans l'atmosphère.
On peut voir la combinaison
de toutes ces différentes choses
qui se produisent en même temps
et on peut se poser de plus intéressantes questions encore.
Comment la pollution de l'air et le climat coexistent-ils ?
Pouvons-nous changer des choses
qui agissent sur la pollution et sur le climat en même temps ?
La réponse est oui.
Voici l'historique du 20e siècle.
l'animation du haut, c'est le modèle.
La météo est un peu différente
de ce qui s'est réellement produit.
L'animation du bas, ce sont les observations.
Nous traversons les années 1930.
Il y a de la variabilité, beaucoup de choses se produisent,
Mais ce ne sont que des parasites.
À mesure que l'on approche des années 1970,
les choses vont commencer à changer.
Ils vont commencer à se ressembler
et lorsqu'on arrive aux années 2000,
vous pouvez constater le modèle du réchauffement climatique.
dans les observations comme dans le modèle.
Nous savons ce qui s'est produit au 20e siècle.
Vrai ? Nous savons que la Terre se réchauffe.
Nous savons où ça se réchauffe.
Si vous interrogez les modèles pour savoir pourquoi cela s'est produit,
vous pouvez dire : d'accord, eh bien, oui,
au fond c'est à cause du dioxyde de carbone
que nous émettons dans l'atmosphère.
Nos prédictions sont très bonnes
jusqu'à maintenant.
Il y a une raison fondamentale pour expliquer la consultation des modèles,
c'est à cause de cette phrase :
parce que si nous avions des observations provenant du futur,
nous y ferions plus confiance qu'en nos modèles
mais malheureusement,
les observations du futur ne sont pas disponibles encore.
Quand nous nous projetons dans le futur, il y a une différence.
On ne connaît pas le futur, il est incertain
et nous avons des options.
Voici les options que nous avons.
Nous pouvons travailler afin d'atténuer
nos émissions de dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère.
C'est l'option qui est en haut.
Nous pouvons travailler encore plus
pour vraiment les diminuer
pour qu'à la fin de ce siècle,
il n'y en ait pas plus qu'aujourd'hui.
Ou bien nous pouvons nous en remettre au destin
et continuer
comme si de rien était.
Les différences entre ces options
ne peuvent pas être mesurées en consultant des modèles.
Une célèbre phrase
de Sherwood Rowland,
prix Nobel de chimie
pour sa théorie sur la diminution de l'ozone,
lorsqu'il accepta son Prix,
il a posé cette question :
« Quelle est l'utilité d'avoir développé une science
assez pour pouvoir faire des prédictions, si, au bout du compte,
tout ce que nous sommes prêts à faire, c'est de rester là
à attendre que ça se produise ? »
Les modèles sont utiles,
mais ce que pouvons nous faire de l'information collectée
est de notre ressort.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)